hello everyone i welcome you all to the
webinar on winter research fellowship
program this research fellowship program
has been designed to help young
researchers and students take advantage
of the bioinformatics resources for
analysis of complex high throughput life
science data and become versed in
bioinformatics this program offers you
to participate in real and cutting-edge
bioinformatics research and to be a part
of renowned bioinformatics community
omix logic is an international program
that is running in five different
regions with over 15 000 users around
the world and due to this fast growth
our team is working with local and
regional coordinators that are helping
refine the program logistics and
leverage our online training resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
our mixed logic programs follow a
based learning approach using research
grade tools to analyze data from top
peer reviewed journals and also the
training has been completed by over 10
000 participants from 162 countries in
over 300 workshops for six different
specialization tracks being oncology
infectious diseases precision medicine
neuroscience data science for biomedical
data and comprehensive training on omix
data analysis
our training is designed to allow
participants to apply methods to curated
and new data sets and develop
independent projects that showcase what
has been learnt in the context of a
personal portfolio of projects
as a result anyone starting on this
journey in bioinformatics can start
developing a project of their own
in fact we have already worked with many
students who have completed this kind of
training and developed interesting
research projects that won awards and
got published in peer-reviewed journals
as well
in this session you will hear about some
of the critical points that makes the
project ready for a peer review we will
discuss the structure of the program and
also here about network of campuses
expert mentors and we will also hear
updates from students and mentors who
are supposed to complete the projects
and learn about various resources that
are covered in the program
the resources that are covered in the
program includes the omixlogic courses
on bioinformatics precision medicine
multi-omics including genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics as well data science that
includes bioinformatics using r and
python and the structural aspects of
biology that is chem informatics as a
part of the program you would also get
the access to the example projects from
different fields which you could learn
from and replicate for your own research
work
you can also explore various projects by
our research fellows in various fields
including neurosciences genomics
transcriptomics infectious diseases etc
now i would like to pass on the stage to
our mentors for further discussion about
the program and at first i would like to
invite elia broski ceo pinebiotes to uh
talk more about the structure of the
program and why is it really important
for you all to work on a research
project over to eurea
thank you very much
so
um
it's exciting to see many of you join
today and i think that many of you are
probably wondering
what makes this program different or
special
in the
available programs online where you can
learn about bioinformatics you can learn
about data science the reason why we
developed this program
is specifically to go beyond training
and offer an opportunity to participate
in meaningful research now in today's
session we're going to address many of
the challenges that are associated with
research projects especially getting
those research projects completed in a
short amount of time because typically
they do take years
at the minimum
several months and so what i want to
talk to you today about are some of the
critical things that we've
distilled into this online program
and introduce you to some of the mentors
to talk about some of the specific
project examples but before we do that
let me briefly address some of these
critical points
one of the things that we've realized is
that when people join our different
training programs
their background in life sciences might
prevent them from really getting deeper
into bioinformatics methods allowing
them to superficially know the
terminology but not really know how to
apply it practically
so i
think that you know many of you will
discover that some of the training
materials that we've designed are
specifically uh useful for those that
come from a life science background
without a lot of technical engineering
skills and then you will be able to
really appreciate both the logic of the
analysis and technically how to become
independent and efficient in
bioinformatics analysis methods
the second area where many students
have faced a challenge is finding an
impactful research topic
and to find that impactful and
meaningful topic
we've addressed this through two
different
approaches the first one is literature
review how to perform literature review
so that you can find
the specific gaps in research and
opportunities for you to do something
new and different and at the same time
find data that you can find answers for
that question that research question so
it's developing the research question
finding the data we review many data
sets with our community to provide you
with a curated start so that you can
start investigating a topic using a
curated data set and then find
opportunities to innovate and ask
questions of these data sets including
introducing you to the
approach of finding data sets online
and then finally the third topic is how
to know that what you have developed is
a meaningful project not just for the
student community but also for the
scientific community and that's why we
have developed a network of mentors that
come from a research as well as industry
background that are able to provide you
with
critical feedback so that your project
becomes more impactful and refine the
project or provide you with suggestions
on how to refine the project to make it
more impactful and
essentially providing with more
visibility and feedback
so before we continue i want to show you
how some of these things are going to
actually take place uh and i want to
introduce you to some of the program
resources really briefly and to do that
i want to
point you to
two servers and and two portals one of
them is going to be the server t-bio
info portal this is going to be a portal
uh that is
designed to provide you with an
opportunity to process big data and also
the learn omics logic
portal where you will find all the
training resources so let's first go to
this portal the omixlogic portal and
thank you adjustment for sharing that
link and i'll also explain how those two
things are linked
so if you go to this portal link
you will find here i think a very clear
explanation of what this portal really
is the omixlogic portal is designed to
provide you with everything to get you
started and get you into these real
world practical challenges with big data
and you will find here tutorials project
examples on how to run various pipelines
and apply different analytical methods
you will find here different types of
research projects that you can get
started with in the fields of oncology
infectious diseases neuroscience
agriculture and others and you will also
find meaningful application of your
logic how do you understand that you can
take raw data and get structured data
that you can analyze and supplement that
with training with coding and machine
learning and data science and analytics
all of the necessary skills that will
make you independent and self-sufficient
as you go forward with your projects
so the first thing that you want to do
is you want to click right here on login
and i will give you a couple of minutes
to complete your registration
so once you click on login you have the
option here to create an account
okay so i will wait a few minutes for
those of you that don't have an account
please take a few moments right now to
fill in your name your email and create
a password it's a free account you don't
have to pay for this but you will
immediately get access to some of the
free resources that are made available
and hopefully they will inspire you
to continue forward with a research
project using bioinformatics so once you
have completed your registration please
share
on the chat box the link to your profile
and i will explain briefly what you can
do with this profile okay so i will show
you my profile
okay once you log in you can click right
here and you will find your profile
open up and so
if you want to share your profile and
just go right here to the url on top
copy this url and you can share this
right here
with everyone in the chat box so please
let me know i'll give it a few minutes
so that
at least a few of you will be able to
complete your profile and share with us
for those of you that already have an
account
thank you aransa for those of you that
already have an account especially the
campus ambassadors that are here in this
session
please share your accounts as well
so we will take some account that is
complete so that we can show how a
completed profile looks
okay thank you
all right great so let's take just one
of these accounts as an example
uh here we have an account by subrajeet
who is already an expert
how do we know that he is an expert
he's an expert first of all because of
the activity that we can already see on
his profile so you can see that all of
your activity as you go through the
lessons as you try different projects as
you try different analysis techniques
are quantified and what that means is
that you get a number of points for
completing each step and that
immediately signals to the mentor
community
that you have accomplished the basic
training and you're ready to get started
with your research project so the way
the research fellowship works is it
starts from this basic training
what is covered in the basic training so
importantly i think in today's world
when we speak about bioinformatics the
major focus is on big data
this big data comes in the form of
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics there are many different
types of omics and ultimately you have
to know how to process each individual
types of data and then integrate them
together to really have this systems
level view of what's happening in a
biological condition and so we've
designed these so that you have an
introduction and i will show you a
couple of courses that you can start
with for free so that you get into this
whole field of omnics data
then you go through this basic training
and then you get introdu introduced to
the data science curriculum in r and
python so i will briefly show you a
couple examples and this is just to get
you started
so again as you can see this profile it
is complete with activity i can see
which courses super gene has completed
and i can also see that he has earned
certificates and those certificates are
going to stay with you unless the course
has been updated and when it's updated
your certificate will be taken away so
that you can complete the remaining
lessons and then get the certificate
back and that way we know that you're
staying up to date on some of these
important topics
in addition to that you can participate
in programs and today we're speaking
about the research fellowship program
but also we have many others that are
led by mentors who are experts in the
field and you will also be able to
develop a project so
as we go through one of the requirements
that this program has is so that you
complete your basic training now where
would you start your basic training
here on the courses tab right here in
the menu
you can find a lot of courses that as
you work through some of the material
will get a personalized suggestion for
your profile so you can see that for me
i have some suggestions on single cell
transcriptomics machine learning ebola
virus etc and that's because of my
interests
but here below i have a list of
recommended and highly
active courses as well as some of the as
well as some of the
collections of courses that you can find
right here and one of the collections is
called getting started so i can just
click right here on getting started
and see what's included
the course that we recommend for all of
you to start with is a course called
bytes and molecules
the course uh explains
many of the basic terms
so
a lot of the basic terms that you need
to know to get into this field and it is
uh
using you know language that anyone can
understand both
with and without
the kind of bioinformatics background
and it covers important topics that you
will want to understand before you
really get into a lot of the material
that is related to research using
bioinformatics so that's just where you
would want to start with
so after you complete
enough material to generate 10 000
points what will be made available
is right here
under projects you will be able to start
a new project and that is essentially
what this program is all about so this
program is going to be
focused on getting beyond the training
after you've completed the 10 000 points
and into a research topic now one of the
immediate challenges with that is how do
you process this huge amount of data
that oftentimes is beyond several
gigabytes or even terabytes of data that
you have to download on your computer
and so for that we specifically designed
a big data analysis platform that will
cover many of the typical processing
steps that reduce the amount of data
from gigabytes and terabytes to just
megabytes which is possible to analyze
either on your system or in the cloud
and we will introduce you to cloud
technologies using this platform called
the t violin for platform developed at
the caliber bioinformatics research
center at university of haifa
as well as some of the cloud
technologies offered by other companies
like google collab github and other
resources that are going to be useful
for you to leverage as you develop your
career in bioinformatics
so here we have i'll just briefly show
you one example as you probably all know
transcriptomic data data on rna
sequencing is becoming more and more
prominent in many different areas of
research including oncology
neuroscience and other fields and
briefly you can appreciate the
simplicity of this platform because it
really organizes the information in a
logical step-by-step process and by the
way this is reflected in the coursework
that you will find on the learn portal
it also guides you using artificial
intelligence based on the data that you
upload and the information that you
would like to receive from this pipeline
so that you can eliminate the common
mistakes that people make when they try
to design these uh workflows on their
own
now as a result of running these
workflows you also get a clear sense of
the logic behind the analysis including
the inputs and outputs of different
methods and so once you're ready to
transition to your own independent
pipeline that you want to build on your
own now you at least understand the
logic why would i use this method and
not that method when would i try to
modify this setting or that setting and
this spans as i mentioned across many
different areas of analysis including
next generation sequencing data mass
spectroscopy structural biology as well
as many methods for data integration and
modeling machine learning and other
types of applications so all of you can
definitely go through some of these
resources the thing is once you've
created an account on the onixler
onyxlogic portal you automatically get
access to the demo level on this
bioinformatics platform after 24 hours
so from the moment that you created a
profile today tomorrow morning you can
already start using this platform seeing
how it is used in different courses and
projects that we will talk about
so this is the t binding platform
now ultimately you're probably wondering
well okay i have these resources i can
go through the training i can understand
what topic i would like to analyze it i
can perform the analysis but how do i
know that i'm doing the right thing
and so to do that we have a community of
mentors and i think that's a very
critical point to
briefly discuss so our community of
mentors first of all is an international
community many of our
mentors come from research backgrounds
many of them have a phd
in a particular domain like
bioinformatics computational biology
neuroscience oncology etc and today you
will hear from some of them
but also many of them come with industry
experience and so for those of you that
understand what you want to do with your
career if you would like to go beyond
basic research and focus on
translational research projects that is
one of the
specific
goals of this program as well as a
research fellow you get to explore a
variety of topics and select one that is
either relevant for industry or for
research and we'll talk about this today
including different collaborations that
we have with universities and
organizations that provide us with this
opportunity to know what is needed and
is in demand at the cutting edge of
basic research and industry r d as well
so what are some of the outcomes the
outcomes of this program is that you
will come out knowing
how to apply bioinformatics to a
particular project and you will be able
to complete that project within a short
period of time and just to give you a
sense of what i mean by that i want to
pass this presentation now to dr
harpreet kapoor she is a mentor with a
background in genomics for oncology
research and has a lot of expertise
working on many different research
publications together with her
collaborators but now she's a mentor and
she has been working with several
research fellows over the past couple
months that will present their updates
on projects so you can get a sense of
where they are and how they got to where
they are
so
dr harpreet i will pass it on to you now
thank you india
let me share my screen
hello everyone myself harpreet and i
have a phd in bioinformatics
in my current role i am curriculum
developer and research consultant
i am mentoring number of research
fellows and working with international
collaborators
on various research projects based on
biomedical and js data so today we will
also see some of the research follow
uh who are presenting their progress on
their respective process but before
their presentation
let me give you a glimpse
of
how
how bioinformatics can be used on
biomedical data to drive significance
meaning by taking some example
from the projects that i have completed
during my doctoral degree and some of
the projects that we have completed
during this research fellowship program
so my phd is in the in the area of
cancer genomics uh specifically liver
cancer so when i went through the
literature i found some of the major
challenges associated with the liver
cancer including
liver cancer is often misdiagnosed or
detected too late for an effective
treatment
another factor that contribute to the
poor outcome for the liver cancer
patient
is the frequent reoccurrence of the
tumor after the treatments
so keeping these concern in mind so we
have worked on several process
so in the first project we used large
scale transcriptomics data to identify a
diagnostic biomarker panel for
hepatocellular carcinoma
in this study we employed 30 dataset
containing nearly 4000 samples
and this data was taken from public
repositories like geo and tcca to
elucidate transcriptomics biomarker
panel for the diagnosis and the
prognosis of the liver cancer
implementing various statistical and
machine learning techniques
for the next project we use
transcriptomics data to scrutinize the
diagnostic biomarker panel for
challengio carcinoma which is another
liver malignancy
in this study we employed nine data set
from public repository mainly geo which
includes 350 calendurocarcinoma 133
adjacent non-tumorous and 90 fcc sample
to scrutinize chlangiocarcinoma specific
trans atomic biomarkers implementing
various
supervised machine learning techniques
like svm random forestry logistic
regression etc
so in the next part we focused on the
prognosis of liver cancer patients so
here in this project we use
transcriptomics
and methylation data of hepatocellular
carcinoma
to identify
biomarker panel that can classify early
in the late stage of liver cancer
so in this study
we have again taken public data from tcc
repository
uh which contain early and late tumor
stage samples so in this study we
identified 51
signatures which include 30 rna
transcripts and 21 methylation cpg site
using a number of
machine learning and statistical
approaches
so in the last part we focused on
identification of multi-ohmic signature
that can stratify
low reoccurrence risk group and high
reoccurrence risk group of scc patients
so in this study we identified 90 rna 50
mi rna 50 methylation and four
integrative features that can able to
significantly stratify reoccurring risk
group of scc patients
so now let me give you the glimpse of
some of the project that completed by a
research fellow in this omics logic
research fellowship program who have not
much background in the bioinformatics
so we have to uh research followers from
various backgrounds and across the globe
so the in the uh here one of the
research fellow
uh miss simaider
uh who is undergraduate student from the
turkey completed her research project
entitled
long non-coding rna as a therapeutic
target in chronic lymphocytic leukemia
using publically available data in
employing various bioinformatics tools
from t by info server which elia has
just shown you
then miss puja parikh
who worked on the project are entitled
identification of biomarker to
differentiate between neural stem cell
and glioblastoma stem cell employing
publicly available data
using various data mining techniques so
today uh miss ujja barik is also going
to present
her our progress on the project
then uh
apart from the oncology process
so then we also worked on various other
areas including neuroscience so here
um our one of the research fellow miss
ruth
completed her project in the field in
the field of multiple sclerosis
so she worked in the project entitled in
silico analysis of transcriptomic
profile profiling and affected
biological pathway in multiple sclerosis
using publicly available data
then besides
uh some of the research of fellows also
worked in the area of space omics
so for example here
ms delara de keen completed her project
in the field of space formics entitled
radiation 3 to humans in space an
alternative approach with probiotics
using metagenomic data and various
bioinformatics
tools from t-band for server
then beside
oncology and neuroscience
then
we also worked in the field of
infectious disease for example
mr supantha day completed her project in
the field of infectious disease
particularly malaria so he worked on a
project entitled analysis of gene
expression profile to study malaria
vaccine dose rpkc and immune response
modulation using transcriptomics data of
the patients and various data mining
techniques
then another example of infectious
diseases project that we have completed
so we completed with our collaborators
from ghana on the project where we have
tried to identify haplotype variants of
the plasmodium falciparum ama1 analysis
based on the genomics data so then apart
from masters or uh graduate
undergraduate students we also worked
with the
high school student so let me give you
the glimpse of the projects that
completed by uh high school is a
research follows so here miss natara
sirini version completed her project in
the field of neuroscience she worked on
the project entitled effect of onset
onset of menopause on the transcriptomic
profiling of easing female brains
besides another research follow
uh mr anders completed his project in
the field of alzheimer's disease
so my major research interest lies in
cancer genomics infectious diseases
neuroscience and machine learning and
specifically my focus is most of the
studies for the biomarker discovery
i'm looking forward to work with many of
you
now i would like to pass this session to
dr mohit mazumdar to talk uh uh
talk about
other research follows but before his
presentation uh
let me invite some of the research
fellows who are currently working on
various projects
so first i would like to invite one of
our research fellow mr avio
so title of his presentation is
identification characterization and
analysis of cell cell wall related genes
as primary targets for efficient biofuel
production in sorghum by bicolor
so
over to ua view so you can share your
progress update
so every uh
are you here
so i think he might be get disconnected
so now i would like to invite our
another research fellow miss ujja parikh
so title of her presentation is in
silico analysis and characterization of
differentially expressed gene to
distinguish glioma stem cells
from neural
normal neural stem cells so over to uh
so here you need to unmute yourself as
well
okay so so nalika can you just uh make
cohost
yeah okay yes
okay i hope i'm audible
yes
all right
i'll share my screen
all right
uh thank you very much dr harfit for
introducing me um i'm gonna be talking
about my project in silicon analysis and
characterization of differentially
expressed genes to distinguish glioma
stem cells from normal neural stem cells
so
a little about myself i'll start my phd
in cancer biology with the german cancer
research center in heidelberg germany
i have pursued my masters and bachelor's
in biomedical science from elementary
university which is in mumbai and i've
also topped my university for the same
course
so with pine biotech i have been working
on this particular project on
glioblastoma where i am trying to elicit
the
differences
in gene expression between normal neural
stem cells and glioma stem cells so
glioblastoma multiform is a very legal
type of brain cancer where patients are
given
an overall survival period of only 15
months post therapy
the reason why this particular brain
cancer is so
aggressive is because of its
heterogeneity and
there are different types of tumors with
different types of expression profiles
so we also currently do not know from
where this particular type of cancer
originates whether it originates from
normal neural stem cells
via transformation of the nominal stem
cell type to the cancerous phenotype or
do they originate directly via the
glioma stem cells
to get a better understanding of the
same i have performed rna sequence
analysis
uh so
what i did was i looked at a current
depository of rna sequence for glioma
stem cells in normal neural stem cells
from which in my previous analysis i
taken 40 samples 20 of normal stem cells
and 20 of glioma stem cells and after
performing rna sequence analysis i got
results where i was able to see a clear
separation between the glioma stem cells
and normal neural stem cells in my pc
analysis
i was also able to observe a clear
separation in the hierarchical
clustering
i was also able to observe
several differentially expressed genes
so 192 genes that were significantly
upregulated in glioma stem cells and 156
down regulated genes in glioma stem
cells in comparison to normal neural
stem cells
so these particular genes are of
importance because they might be playing
an important role in driving glioma
genesis so in order to better understand
its involvement in different pathways i
perform gene ontology studies using
david and keg which are tools for doing
such sort of studies where i was able to
find the involvement of these
particularly uh particular
differentially expressed genes in
pathways uh that are hallmarks of cancer
or tumor genesis like wind signaling
pathway tgf beta pathway wedge of
signaling pathways
um so with literature review of the top
50 significantly differentially
expressed genes i was able to find that
there are several genes uh that are
playing key roles in this particular
type of cancer and there were several
novel genes with currently known
association with glioma genesis
now the reason that i'm extending the
study is because i have taken a very
small sample size and i believe that a
larger sample size is required to get
more relevant findings and i can also
not generalize these particular results
with other types of subsets of
glioblastomas and therefore for the same
reason i am extending the study to
perform something called internal
validation and external validation now i
have taken the smaller data set which
i've already analyzed as my internal
validation data set
i am repeating my uh study of 448
samples of normal neurostem cells and
glioma stem cells and i will also be
performing external validation um for
which i'll be finding uh another type of
normal neural stem cell sample and
glioma stem cell sample and correlate
the findings of my current study with
that other study
so in the current study where i've taken
140 samples of normal neural sensors and
glioma stem cells
i have performed rna sequence analysis i
have received gene counts after
performing that particular pipeline i
have also performed differential gene
expression analysis using bc2 and
eventually i have performed gene
ontology studies human gauge pipelines
in gc to better understand the
involvement of genes enriched in my
particular samples
and how they might be driving this
particular type of cancer
so the first pca that i performed for
the 148 samples that i've considered in
the study you can see that uh i got two
separate clusters for glioma stem cells
and normal stem cells however there were
certain outliers which were normally
used stem cell samples clustered with
glioma stem cell samples
so in my further pcas i removed those
particular outliers and the excessive
genes that may not be of any relevance
um and then finally i got a clear and
separate pca uh showing the two
different types of stem cell samples
as you can see in the third pca plot
i also perform hierarchical clustering
uh currently the plot looks a bit messy
but it basically shows two clusters one
where uh glioma stem cell samples are
and one where the normal neural stem
cell samples are
i have also performed differential gene
expression analysis using bc2
uh where i initially obtained 19
453 differentially expressed genes
however on putting certain filters such
as the pre-adjusted value i
finally got a pre-adjusted value of
lesser than 0.05 i got 397
significantly differentially expressed
genes i later also put a certain
thresholds on the lock to fold change
values uh which was plus 1.5 for
upregulated genes and lesser than minus
1.5 for downregulated genes
so
i got even fewer genes that are more
significantly expressed in these
particular types of glioma stem cells in
comparison to normal neural stem cells
so um i had this massive gene list
but i had to also interpret what these
particular genes mean in terms of glioma
genesis
for which i perform downstream analysis
uh so i will i will be showing you all
um what exactly i've done um using those
particular softwares but basically i've
used david and enliture which are gene
ontology tools where you can insert gene
sets and try and analyze where those
particular genes are involved in what
functions are they involved in i have
also used the human gauge pipeline to
elicit uh the most significant pathways
in which my genes are enriched in and
again gc is something it's a gene set
enrichment analysis again which gives us
um
genes that may be uh
correlated with current hallmark gene
set so like for example we already have
uh certain gene sets that may be
involved in the tgf beta signaling
pathway and there are gene lists that
have already been uh made by other
scientists so basically correlating my
gene set with those known gene sets and
seeing if there is any sort of um
correlation between them so i will just
stop my presentation here and
show you all my results
um
so first i will show you all my
gauge results
where
can you all see my main screen or i was
still able to see my presentation
i think you need to unshare your screen
first and then reshare so that we can
see uh your transition to the other oh
well yeah thank you
yeah okay i hope you can see it now
uh yes we can see thank you
so uh
these are basically keg pathways um
so you can see jeans that are
highlighted in green and red
so these particular genes were present
in my gene list
and they are uh
basically drivers of glioma genesis
uh so you can see that they are involved
in pathways like the calcium signaling
pathway
or the axon guidance pathways
or the focal adhesion pathway
so basically there are different
pathways that have been uh highlighted
by the gauge pipeline which
essentially states that these particular
genes are involved in these particular
pathways so i need to interpret this
data further in order to elicit how this
might be correlated to glioma genesis so
for example we know that ecm receptor
interaction is important for tumor
genesis uh it gets altered when cancer
when a person has cancer so the cells
have an altered ecm receptor interaction
so uh this further needs to be
interpreted which i'll be doing
um
you can also see uh its involvement
acceleration molecules and pathways that
may be responsible for cell adhesion
so these are some of the pathways that
i've got after the human gauge pipeline
apart from that i have also
performed gene set enrichment analysis
using the gc software
um again i have got very large results
for the same
okay
yeah so
so for example this is a heat map of a
particular gene set it's a hallmark gene
set um
for epithelial to mesenchymal transition
so emt is a pathway that occurs during
tumor genesis and there are certain
genes that are highly represented uh in
cancer overall so these particular red
and blue dots is what you can see are
the genes that are expressed in my
particular uh gene set as well and red
means that it is upregulated and blue
means it's down regulated so on the left
hand side of this heat map you can see
that there are glioma stem cells and on
the right hand side in yellow are the
normal neural stem cells so you can see
that there are certain genes that are
upregulated in glioma stem cells and
down regulated in normal neural stem
cells
this is a more in-depth plot of several
genes that are upregulated in glioma
stem cells and down regulated in normal
neural stem cells
and again there are certain genes that
are upregulated in normally your stem
cells but down regulated in glioma stem
cells so it kind of shows uh the
differences of gene expression in both
these types of stem cell samples and
they differ
quite a lot
the other uh interesting finding i got
from my gc analysis
uh is
uh so there are different types of uh
subtypes of glioblastoma so there is a
mesenchymal subtype or a pro neural
subtype so i have got different plots
heat maps for the mesenchymal
geoblastoma subtype as well as the uh
pronunced subtype
so i again need to like classify what
kind of whether my no the the neural
stem cells that i have taken into
consideration what kind of subtype do
they fall under for the glioblastoma
tumor classification
so uh there is a lot to look at because
i have used uh several different types
of gene sets from gc
uh to try and understand the gene sets
that might be enriched in my particular
study
so yeah this is just like a
general heat map of
my particular study
apart from that i have also
used in richer
and david
so
i have put in the genes that are
upregulated uh in my particular data set
and i have uh uploaded them on enricher
so on nhl basically i can
see what kind of transcription pathways
or ontologies or diseases
my particular gene set might be enriched
in so currently because there are so
many results i'm still trying to cut
down on the most relevant or most
important results and try and elicit um
how my gene sets might be involved in
these particular pathways that are shown
over here
so i i do kind of need help with that
so yeah currently i am on the part where
i am still trying to interpret the
meaning of the
uh thousands of genes that i have got
out of my rna-seq analysis or
differential gene expression analysis
and what i further intend to do is um
compare these results with the results
that i have got from the uh
40 samples i had previously analyzed and
also compare these particular results
with an external data set so that i can
say that these particular results that i
have got can be generalized and these
might be important uh drivers of glioma
genesis overall
so
i hope
you all have understood what i have been
trying to do and i would love to get
some feedback on the same
thank you
uh for sharing wonderful presentation
and yeah for the pathway analysis you
can go i mean uh analyze it first like
what are the important specifically
based on log to four chains and the p
adjusted value you can find what are the
important pathways because you have lot
of lists so just go into the uh table
where you have pathway or a gene
ontology term corresponding p or p
adjusted value so try to select only
important uh
important pathways at least uh p
adjusted value less than point zero five
i think then you can get important
pathways here
okay
okay so now i would uh
uh ask uh ilya and dr vinder to give um
comments on your presentation or any
suggestion that they have
yeah thank you i think overall it's
clear that you've done a lot of work and
now the task ahead is to integrate all
these analysis results and kind of make
sense of what are the clear findings
i think because of the time constraints
this is an exciting update to the
project that you've been working on for
a while and you're obviously addressing
a lot of the issues that came up during
the initial analysis
let's move on to hear a little bit from
dr raghav
who is another mentor and then he can
transition to his part of the
presentation so thank you urjah
thank you thank you elia
i think i'm audible so that that was a
very that was a very detailed and very
good work oja and i'll be interested to
see uh okay
yes okay great so i'll be i'm very much
interested to see the pathway associated
with it and then you can
do
do selected and selected analysis on the
pathway that are shared or that are not
shared completely different between the
normal
stem cells and the glio glioma stem
cells so those are very interesting uh
ones
maybe maybe a even more stringent uh p
value could give you a
reduced set of genes
because you you still have a lot of
genes to analyze and that would
yeah so you can maybe maybe you can
reduce your analysis or downstream
analysis to top
20 or top 15
up regulated genes and top 20 down
regulated genes for each set and then
try to see
if these top 20 genes are from multiple
pathways or the pathways associated with
these top two digits that should
narrow it down and make your analysis
even more workable because
i mean at the moment you have really a
lot of data to uh comprehend with so
right now we i would start with that and
then uh and see where it goes and and
maybe extend it to uh
top 50 if if that is that makes even
more meaningful even more meaning and
and
we will see
yeah
okay so uh
thank you yes
so i think that will
that will translate or transition to my
talk or presentation
i will share my screen right away
i just need to find it well okay
okay
excellent
okay
that was
okay great can everybody see my screen
i think you can
yeah yes so we can thank you so yeah
thank you
i am raghavendran bioinformatics mentor
and research consultant with omixlogic
let me brief you about my my background
and research interests
so i grew up to be a tinkerer kid who is
interested in solving many problems so
right in my younger ages computers and
programming with computers introduced me
to very new puzzles and challenges so
attempting to solve these puzzles and
these challenges were the first step
that took me towards solving puzzles and
asking questions so during my undergrad
education i read about the potential and
the announcement of the human genome
project
that
yeah
and that was the first research article
that i read i didn't understand it most
of it but it it inspired me uh to a
great deal and i pursued my master's in
biophysics so my natural inclination
towards computers and structural biology
bioinformatics led me to specialization
in computational biology and
bioinformatics so uh after my master's
in
bioinformatics uh biology biophysics
i joined phd in max plant institute
for biophysical chemistry uh with the
specialization in computational biology
so uh during this tenure i developed
software and designed a lot of
methodologies and pipelines for protein
structural and dynamic studies so my
system of interest during this during
the phd period was proteins associated
with neurodegenerative diseases
so uh when
at the time when the next gene
sequencing technologies
were starting to get established in
india i came back to india as a postdoc
to the institute of bioinformatics and
applied biotechnology in bengaluru
the potential of the nitrogen sequencing
technique and its application to
multi-omics data analysis these two
combined and piqued my interest in
cancer so you all know
cancer is the leading cause of disease
death worldwide so
i got naturally inspired and
interested to work with cancer biology
so i contacted professor chandra ramadan
jainu and dr pedro balaster in in
collaboration with dr pedro ballasted in
insulin france
i proposed a study to understand and to
explore humor responses to different
treatment achievements
so
this was while i was in bengaluru and i
also agreed to help a friend
who was in need of bioinformatics help
in
the renewable genome assembly of a
variety of mean plant so it was only
during this collaborative project i came
to realize how little information was
available for plant bioinformatics in
the public repositories while when you
take or when you compare it with
availability of databases and the
repositories for human or bacteria
there is hardly anything for the plants
but there is so much potential to
understand uh plant genetics because
through bioinformatics and through
sequencing techniques
we can understand the underlying biology
of plant genetics because agricultural
crops have been subjected to artificial
selection for ages irrespective of uh
geographical location and irrespective
of culture
so i i continue to work with the project
and they are writing up the paper and
i'm still associated with the
department to
for some troubleshooting in the pipeline
that i developed
so while
while all this was going on
the project that we proposed was
successfully funded and so i joined jnu
as a post-op research scientist so uh i
will detail more about the data that i
use for projects and and about the
projects in the discussion uh results in
uh in a short but uh i just wanted to
mention right from my phd years i
enjoyed working with undergrad students
and enjoyed working with students so uh
this experience tremendously inspires me
and i feel privileged to work with some
of the bright young minds
so uh i hope and i wish every one of you
will enjoy working with me and as much
as i look forward to working with you
so uh for the next two slides or the
next two slides i want to move on to
speak about the data that i use for the
project on precision oncology let's see
if i can get this yes okay great
so
every once in a while in in science that
groundbreaking research gets published
and the data collected for that work
content contains a lot of potential to
answer a wide variety of scientific
questions and queries so this is one
such paper
and this paper is about tumor cells that
are grafted into most models
to to study
tumor responses to different treatment
agents so what they did was they
extracted the tumor cells from cancer
patients and then they
they sequenced it and from the sequence
they
profiled the gene expression levels and
the gene mutation levels and the copy
number variation levels and then these
tumor cells are grafted into
immunosuppressant mouse
so and these mouse were administered
different and
different set of treatment regimes
and
and
and the tumors response to these
treatment regimes were studied and such
mouse or such immunosuppressant mouse
which got administered with
tumor grafts are known as patient
derived xenografts so these pdxs in
short and they are administered 60
different treatments and
and their response were recorded
in change in volume and the ability of
the mouse to survive the disease
so such survival data analysis of 1075
pdx mouse was released along with this
data along with the study so this study
from this analysis concludes that the
mouse models provide a better
alternative compared to the cell lines
which were traditionally used because
cell lines are often affected by the
petri dishes they have grown on and
heterogeneity is one of the biggest
problem in cell line data
so far and
at the basic genomic level compared to
the cell lines the genes the uh the gene
expression levels of the pdxs resemble
more to the tran uh to the cancer
patients than the cell lines solving
data and
and
pdxs are also consistent or the data of
these pdxs are also consistent with
extensively study therapies and
this comparison validates their
applicability to understand the
underlying cancer biology so such a
wealthy of data generates a plethora of
research questions as i already post so
one can employ this data to various
analytical pipelines to study treatment
stratification like can the mutations in
genomic data predict tumor resistance or
vice versa can tumor resistance uh
relate to significant mutations in those
models or
are combination of drugs more effective
than single drugs or how how does
different combinations of drug work well
or does not work well together or can we
find the underlying biology behind this
or we can also do some precision
medicine study like
do targeted therapy exhibit higher
efficacy than general cytotoxic
treatments because
among these sixty treatments some were
general cytotoxic treatments which are
toxic to all cells just they kill cancer
cells more than the normal cells and
some are
some specifically target pathways inside
the cancer cells so can we find out
the underlying differences between these
two treatments
and with the help of multi-omix
integration
can the pdxs broadly represent
the interpretation diversity because
that was one of the biggest conclusion
of this study where they observed
a diversity among the models which carry
the same cancer cells
from different patients so they
they translate into inter patient
diversity so can we quantify this
diversity or more importantly can we
find the commonality among this
diversity so that we can understand or
we can use it for biomarker analysis so
these are different questions and what
it i used to
use this study to
work on so
my aim was to use this pdx data to
design and implement machine learning
models to predict tumor responses to
different treatment regimes and why do
we need to do that so the efficacy or
the effectiveness of the cancer drugs is
very strongly patient dependent that is
why we are moving more and more towards
precision oncology and personalized
medicine because on an average only 25
percentage of the cancer patients
actually respond to cancer drugs
but unlike unlike
your normal painkillers
you will have 80 percentage of the
patients responding positively to the
painkillers so currently there is a need
to predict which patient will respond
positively to the treatment and if not
there is no need to spend time and
energy and to treat the patients with
the treatment so
for this study one obviously cannot use
patient data because of
because of the difficulty the uniformity
among the patient data but we can
actually use
these most model data to predict the
treatment response so how did i do that
the gene expression data the copy number
variation data and the gene mutation
data were the features from which the
machine learning models defines a
function to understand the tumor
response so when this model was
presented a test case it tries to
predict the tumor response to the
particular drug
so such a study this this model was
applied to breast cancer and colorectal
cancer pdxs which were treated for 26
different treatments
so what did we find
traditionally canonically single genes
were used as biomarkers that predict the
onset of cancer and the same sort of
single genes were used as a as a
treatment biomarker also
for example
if if there is an association of a gene
to the onset of cancer the same gene was
ah
study whether this particular cancer
will respond positively or negatively to
any given treatment this is obviously
and
logically is not a very accurate
predictor so that so this this is not a
very successful
model but uh
from
from a very uh from the multi data
analysis what we uh demonstrate is
the uh
before that i want to uh before that i
want to introduce you to the accuracy
measure that we are measuring the tree
measuring the
machine learning model's
accuracy levels so this is matthew's
correlation coefficient where an
accuracy of 1 would mean the perfect
accuracy like all the test data or
perfectly
identified or predicted to be
how it responded to the treatment and
minus one would be complete opposite if
there is a positive response the model
predicts a negative
response and around zero would be a
random response so what we want is these
data points to move more more towards
one
so that we get better accuracy of our
machine learning model so uh
in that one so when the machine learning
model was uh
used uh used to predict on single gene
markers you see the accuracy is not very
great it is it's actually yeah
it's very bad
so
when multi-gene models were introduced
in place of single gene models the
accuracy is improved and
the accuracy level can further be
improved by
combining or by including more than one
profiles or more than one molecular
profile like
gene mutation data combined with
gene expression data combined with copy
number variation data improves accuracy
tremendously so to quantify we actually
observed we could predict
19 out of 26
treatment regimes
we could predict correctly 19 out of 26
treatment regimes so
uh
this was what we performed and what
could be done what could be done more in
in such a study so one can extend such
an analysis to include patient data from
tcga repository but that involves
extensive curation of the data but one
can still do it
a gene set enrichment analysis like what
oja presented
of the biomarker genes will throw
insight into the biology behind the
response of these tumors to different
treatment levels so
this is how we did and
such a study was actually performed for
selected cancer and for selective
treatments so one can obviously extend
the study to all the cancer to find the
commonality of these cancer cells to
react to different treatment regimes so
these are the different future
steps that the team is currently working
on but i finished my part and i joined
pomex logic
so i hope this project was informative
and it does inspire you to utilize
curated pdx data this curated pdx data
will be available at the omixlogix
platform shortly and this um yeah
this platform as you are aware by now
with uh different uh introduction from
elia and from uh harpreet and from
sonalika provides a very well organized
research fellowship program that i want
to speak about in the next two slides
let me go to the next slide so yes so uh
from my research experience there are
three main challenges that all
researchers will need to overcome in any
research program and this research
program is designed to target
specifically to address these one
time so a lot of time is actually spent
on learning research methods from
multiple sources with the varying level
of liability but in the end you are
going to use only one or two methods for
your question of interest so what we
have the the learning platform the omics
logic learning platform provides you
with a very well planned learning
modules and coursework this coursework
will prepare you for any challenges you
might face with the data analysis and or
the biological interpretation of your
data analysis and your research question
and
another big challenge in doing
computational work or bioinformatics
work is
is the presence of or is rather there is
a limited access to bioinformatics
expertise or a reduced availability to
bioinformatics experts
for the students so
with
in this program the research fellows
will participate in cutting-edge
bioinformatics research led by mentors
like me
like harpreet and several other mentors
you will find information on the website
we have years of expertise in
computational biology bioinformatics and
also including emerging domains like
spaceomics so this network of mentors
that we have will provide you with
expert feedback and peer review from the
inception of your topic to the final
results and these results will be worthy
to be sharing among the scientific
community and to the world
and and one final challenge is limited
access to infrastructure that is
required to perform big data analysis
this is i think this is the most
important challenge that
many students face right now
so uh
the cloud-based analytical uh turbo
bioinformatics platform that you are
introduced to to today it provides all
the infrastructures that is necessary to
perform big data analysis in an
intuitive environment with the help of
flexible interactive and visual
pipelines so the research fellows will
get access to this platform and a list
of curated public data sets with which
you can design a big data analytics
pipeline on multi-umix data or one can
perform translation research or one can
address clinical questions or biomarker
identification or treatment
certification or variety of question
that you can think about leveraging this
data and infrastructure
so who can benefit from such a research
fellowship program
so
this research fellowship program has
been designed to help young research and
students like you to gain access to the
premium resources on bioinformatics for
the analysis of complex high throughput
data sets that i presented before and uh
like dr harpieth also presented and also
we
observed from oja also so
and the experts will help you complete a
research study on your own so if you are
an undergraduate or a master's student
you can actually engage in research and
you can develop a deeper understanding
of the subject matter than that is
possible through uh through your
classroom routines or classroom
instructions alone so such an early
exposure to research has been proven to
be very helpful and can uh can be the
perfect launchpad for your carrier
you can also apply the skills that is
that is that is one of the most
important point you can apply all the
skills practically the skills that you
learn from your classroom instructions
to a project of your own and to the
project of your
that peaks your interest
and and more
[Music]
documentation wise you can fulfill the
requirements set by your university uh
said by your university syllabus or
curriculum so if you are a research
student so we provide uh you will get an
excellent opportunity to work one-on-one
with the network of mentors and to use
the tbio big data infrastructure
to be part of your research question or
to be an independent study to develop
new skills that ever interested you
interested to do that so with that uh i
thank you all for your
for your
interest and uh attention and this
concludes my presentation and i think i
would like to pass the stage to uh
subrajid barua he's an astrobiologist
and he works on space omics and space
health management
it's very exciting i'll to hear from you
bridget please take over the stage
well thank you so much dr raghav and it
was lovely hearing to you and your
perspective towards bioinformatics which
you said it was amazing to learn about
any other any questions
yeah please go ahead
sure um
so it was amazing to learn and i hope
that our audience also has enjoyed every
bit of it and i hope that everybody is
as excited as i am
for
this particular research opportunity
which we call the research fellowship
now quickly i would just
talk about
a student club which is called cyanics
and
what is the agenda of this
club what are we targeting to do and
what would you benefit by being a part
of it well
hello everyone and thanks for tuning in
to today's webinar it was amazing to see
you all here meet you virtually and also
learn about such amazing opportunities
and research going around and i'm sure
that you are also kind of interested or
already starting to hope that what can
you do and how can you contribute and
how can you also be a part of this
exciting community well that's something
that i am going to talk about today so
my name is subrajet barua and i am the
scientific outreach coordinator at find
biotech and i'm also the president of
the psionics student club
i have an ms in molecular biology and
biotechnology from university saint
petersburg
russia and i am a researcher at the
international laboratory of solutions
chemistry and applied technologies
well to begin with psionics have been
making an impact all throughout the
globe since its inception we have
a huge community of more than 1 000
enthusiasts all over the world we have
been
exposed to more than 20 great scientists
and their webinars all throughout we
also have a very strong alumni network
that consists of more than 30 successful
candidates from all over the world who
have been a part of a mixed logic
research fellowship or
find biotech's research internships and
now they are out in the world making an
impact making a difference all
throughout the flow
so
let me talk a little bit about
what psionics is all about and to do
that i would begin with a very simple
story of every student because you know
i have been a student i am a student
even now so i pretty well recognize
every student going through something of
this sort well
i know that you guys would also agree
and if you can
agree to that do let me know in the chat
section that we do get interested in
doing a research very often right we get
some idea we get to know about some
information we watch some webinars some
presentations and we are so hyped up to
begin our own research journey maybe we
have a task to do we have a an
internship to do our a project to submit
as a part of our college curriculum so
we do get interested in doing a research
but there are certain barriers because
of which we are unable to complete it or
even if we complete it then
we are not very satisfied with whatever
we get and we just hope that there would
have been something better that we could
have done
so what are these barriers well
sometimes we are unable to define a
proper research question which is of
relevance and which would be appreciated
by the scientific community because the
scientific community is so dynamic it
keeps on changing every day so maybe we
are not able to define the question as
required
sometimes we face one of the major
hurdles while doing any research project
is we can't find a good data set just
like dr raghava and also elia earlier
was talking about that finding a good
data set which is curated and which is
worthy of analysis by automatically
using the various tools and algorithms
statistically is a major challenge and a
very difficult task
finally
there can also arise a lack of skill
sets which are required in this modern
world
well we might know a lot of skills we
might have experience in many things but
you know
the world changes so fast so maybe we
need to develop and increase the level
of expertise that we have in the current
technologies out there in the world
but
why a student can't address these issues
well there can be various reasons some
of the possible reasons might be there's
no one to guide this particular student
they don't find someone enough close to
them who they can express their problem
their situation and who can be
like a mentor to them then maybe they
have some supervisors in their college
or their laboratories but they're too
scared or shy to talk to them and
consult them and maybe they often think
that the question that they have or the
doubt that they are bearing in their
mind is too silly to ask someone
they might not know the places where you
can find good quality data for your
analysis out there which are publicly
available for anyone to analyze but we
don't really have the knowledge of where
to look for the data
finally there can be a major issue of
lack of motivation we might have that
enthusiasm to begin with a project but
maybe in the long run we just lose it
and we just pile it up somewhere up
there in a trunk well
these are the
reasons or the issues which psionics
like to address at psionics we have a
huge community of experts and students
from all over the world with various
levels of experience and backgrounds
whom you can think of as your friend
philosopher guide whom you can talk to
there's no need to be shy because if you
join our community every day you will
find someone posting some questions
which might be uh not very big in a
matter of issue but it's definitely
treated with respect by every member of
the cyanics club because
we have been there we all have been
there we have all started from level
zero so
it's like that particular friend whom
you have always been
hoping for to arrive in your life for
with whom you can talk with whom you can
discuss get advice and move on with your
research life also at find biotech just
as we heard from all the experts today
we have great
scientists with
loads of experience in academia and
industry who are there to guide you and
who can be your mentors for
making your research project actually
take shape and finally when you work in
a group when you see others progressing
you also develop that motivation to get
to the table to
power on your laptop and to get started
with your project to be at par with
everyone in that particular community so
that healthy competition atmosphere
motivates each one of us to make get the
best out of ourselves
so
here at psionics we would like to help
you
first of all to get a very good research
idea or a research question which is at
par with what's happening all around the
world right now
which you can get by attending several
guest lectures which would be absolutely
free of cost and they would be twice
every month so you get to attend their
lectures listen to them get their
advices learn about various
opportunities about research going on
around the world what's the cutting edge
situation right now in one particular
domain what's the skill sets required to
start your own research project then you
would get great mentors at find biotech
who can help you out with refining your
question with refining your idea and
also helping you out with the various
skills or the tools that you may need to
perform this particular research the
methods
finally you can
obviously talk to other peers who are
part of this club discuss problems
clarify your doubts talk about certain
errors that you might be coming across
in your particular
research project or talk about new
challenges which you can solve together
so that's a place where it happens where
you get new ideas and finally you would
also get access to various training
programs which would be launched by find
biotech in the near future which you can
get enrolled in to develop new skill
sets that are very much prominent in
today's world
so briefly i would like to talk about
what are the various areas of interests
to us the club members as well as to our
mentors well for example the buzzword
cancer we are interested in learning how
bioinformatics is changing the way we
treat cancer the way cancer research is
progressing and bioinformatics is at the
core of those sort of research so that
is definitely our number one interest we
are also very much interested in looking
at various metabolic diseases like
diabetes and also
we are interested in
knowing and learning the role of
bioinformatics in treating infectious
diseases like cova 19 and ultimately
vaccine development because as you might
know the
rapid development of vaccines all around
the world was
facilitated
with the help of bioinformatics
especially and there's lots more that's
going on and that interests us many of
them are very new to this domain of
bioinformatics and omics for example
personalized medicine although not so
new but it's something which we are
beginning to get a grasp of at a very
young
level of our career so that's really
another exciting domain which we would
love to learn more from the guests and
from the experts and the mentors that we
have
chemi informatics that is a use of
bioinformatics to develop drug targets
and drug candidates with the help of
molecular docking and other tools that's
also something which
really interests us
then comes my favorite area of
research which is astrobiology which
specifically is looking for molecular
signatures or biological signatures
throughout the universe not only limited
by the conditions on earth but also
beyond and not only that but also to
analyze the effects of space flight the
hazardous environment on the molecule
level of the astronauts and to actually
leverage bioinformatics to understand
what's going on in their bodies in the
cells and to use that knowledge
to transform the healthcare system on
earth itself there are numerous examples
of how that is being done but we will
talk about that maybe on one of the
cyanics club sessions so
definitely do consider joining the club
then there's agrobiotic and much much
more that's going on
but the most exciting part which you
would get exposed to by being a part of
cyanics club and also by being in close
contact with fine biotic is something
which is known as faculty-led projects
so pine biotech has a lot of
collaborations going on with
universities and other organizations all
around the world and every university or
organization have a big
number of faculties who are interested
in one particular domain of their
research they have been working on that
domain for years they have done their
phds their post docs and many years of
research in those particular areas now
what you get as a benefit by being a
part of this community is sometimes it
might so happen that you do not have a
research idea or a question of your own
yet because you are starting out right
now you are in the first or the second
year or the third year of your undergrad
and you're really getting exposed to
bioinformatics for the first time that's
pretty normal i have been at that place
myself even
so what's the best way to get started at
that particular level is to get or to
join a team of some great faculty all
around the world who are working on
their projects and you just get to stand
with them and look at their projects
look at the methods that they are using
look at how they are addressing the
various challenges how they are shaping
their question and you get to learn a
lot by doing that now
as you might understand it's often not
possible to
contact those faculties to go to their
organization to go to their places the
only time you can do that is when you go
for a research internship or something
like that and that's also for a short
period of time like three months
but the major advantage that you get by
being a part of psyopolics and also by
staying in close contact with find
biotech as you get exposed to such
faculty-led project opportunities all
throughout the world not only in your
country but also beyond now you can
participate in their research teams get
to work closely with them attend team
meetings get to know the ways and the
strategies they are developing to
address the challenges and the way they
are formulating their research project
and i find this particular opportunity
really exciting because it can transform
your entire career of bioinformatics
research in the future
so how would specifically our mentors
and the courses which elias showed you
in the beginning of the webinar that are
already listed in the portal help you
with your research project and
to
really get started with your research
journey well they would help you to
put together all the pieces of the
puzzle to do our research is a big
puzzle because there are various pieces
like literature review finding a
good data set finding or defining a good
research question then
bringing together all the required
methods interpreting the results and
coming up with the conclusion these are
all pieces of a puzzle but if they can
be put together in a logical way they
would look a beautiful picture like we
see in a jigsaw puzzle so
that expertise that guide us to do that
will be provided by our mentors and all
the asynchronous courses that you can go
through yourself and also give you a
direction in which you can head
in the future
where you could get a master degree or a
phd or maybe a job opportunity in the
future all of this guidance and these
information would be provided by our
mentors and you would get that if you
are a part of the psionics students club
now this model of whatever i said has
been tested and proven by various
students but today i would like to share
my experience or my journey in brief
that how i benefited personally from
this sort of model so how i started
learning bioinformatics as a young
student who's doing his undergrad and
knows nothing about bioinformatics heard
the term for the first time literally
and ending up becoming a space omics
researcher which is completely a niche
domain which is practically very new and
very few people are working in this
particular domain
so
as
you might have guessed i was also a
research intern at fine biotic that's
where i got baptized in bioinformatics
got to know about the various tools got
to know about what is data science in
biology
how accumulated data set looks like how
we can use the various pipelines the
various tools interpret the results
formulate a research question
give shape to a research project
everything i learned here so you can see
that was my certificate of the
internship that i did and here are some
other certificates that i earned by
going through the various tutorials out
there in the pine bedding portal so this
is a place where i got all the necessary
information to begin with
and then
one fine day i was looking through
television and various other blogs so as
you might have already known you guys
have also come across various shows and
such uh materials in discovery or any
other
channels that astronauts face a lot of
problems when they embark on a space
mission when they go to space and that's
all because of microgravity radiation
isolation etcetera etcetera like bone
and muscle density loss physical strain
cancer gut microbiome changes etc etc
but that's not where i stopped i took
one step further to translate this
information or this need for
looking into this particular domain to
convert it into my research interest and
convert it into my research project so
that's where again i got connected with
mybiotic i approached them with my idea
and they were very happy to welcome this
idea although it was new and a very
niche domain they helped me all
throughout the journey the excellent
mentors at find biotech helped me at
every stage helped me address every
challenge that i faced and finally i
could devise some result out of the
research question that i had which
gets aligned to nasa's human research
program that is basically to identify
and to address the challenges faced by
human beings on inside the space
conditions so as you might see some of
those research are already in the
pre-print condition right now and they
are i'm hoping that they will get
published but that's not where i stop
because
this is just the beginning now i am
looking towards other data sets more
complex data sets more complex organisms
to look into and more complex pathways
and biological processes which are out
there to be analyzed these data sets are
available in the public domain
what they require is a proper interest
the proper motivation and the proper
guidance to analyze and get something
very meaningful and helpful
like useful from those particular data
sets and that's how being a part of this
rich community helps you that's how much
the bigger part of the community can
elevate your ideologies and your
experiences
and as you might
have already guessed
this is where everybody of us once have
been the stage where we get an idea
and this is where we want to be we want
to be successful we want to make an
impact we want to announce ourselves
into this domain that yeah we have also
done something but there's a big gap
between that those two areas and that's
the gap which cyanics loves to bridge
and that's our vision to provide you
with the necessary amount of guidance
the necessary amount of resources
information and tools to go from here to
here and make an impact into the world
so
in a nutshell the agenda of psionics
looks like this we would help you to
learn about the current research
standards and challenges present out
there in various domains of interests
all throughout we would also help you
and provide access to various new skills
and also our mentors would help you
define impactful research questions and
finally
our community would also help you to
interpret results publish in various
journals or present it in some great
conferences all throughout
how do we aim to provide you the
information well as i said by inviting
guests who have lots of experience from
all over the world
in various domains for a webinar which
you can attend for free and here's what
the timeline which is quite tentative
but still is in our action of plan
so in november we have the theme of
cancer so we will be having two great
speakers talk about cancer their
research opportunities in december we
would have infectious diseases in
january we will talk about astrobiology
in february metagenomics microbiome
and march personalized medicine and so
on and so forth it will go on and on
without stop and every month there would
be a new theme a new particular domain
of science and bioinformatics which
would be addressed talked about and all
of you are welcome to be a part of it so
if
all of this sounds exciting and good to
you do consider joining cyomics today
it's absolutely free of cost we do not
charge anything to be a part of psionics
and to get access to the community as
well as the various guest lectures so
you can join us through whatsapp so
through telegram or slash channels the
details will be shared you can also find
all those details on social media
platforms of fine biotech or my social
media platform so if you want to stay in
touch with me get in touch with me via
linkedin or instagram or twitter and i
would love to talk to you and if you
guys have any questions feel free to put
them in the chat i would love to address
them and finally hope to see you in the
next ionic sessions good luck with your
research journey and i wish all of you
all the best
so
right now i would
pass it on to sonalika to take the
session further thank you so much for
listening to me today
thank you so much subrashi for sharing
with us about the psionics class i'm
sure the club is doing some amazing work
and i have also shared the link of the
slack group with you all so this is what
the stack group looks like
and if you have registered yourself on
the program page then you are going to
get the invitation to be a part of the
slack channel automatically so all you
need to do just click on the link and
you will be redirected to the slack
channel also we have a sky group at the
details of which has already been shared
in the chat box
so now uh
we i'll be just taking you all uh with
the registration process and also many
of you asked about these scholarships so
let's now discuss how you proceed for to
enroll yourself for this very exciting
research fellowship program and get
started with your research project
so uh
once you visit this research fellowship
program page you are going to get all
the details that you are supposed to
know uh for the program and today we
discussed these three steps in greater
detail that is you are going to get
ready through training and then find an
impactful research topic and present
your analysis for expert feedback the
three major outcomes of the research
fellowship uh program could be either
you could come up with a literature
review or present your research work uh
in a poster presentation competition
maybe and the third one is definitely is
definitely publishing your research work
in repetitive journals
and here on the program page itself
you'll get the details of all the
mentors
you heard from some of the mentors today
and also you could register yourself in
the form here which is mentioned in the
program page uh and once you register
yourself you are going to get all the
details about how you can further enroll
yourself for the program and how to get
started
now we do understand the need to make
this program reasonable for students
along with the basic requirement of
sustaining the program all together so
we have designed this new uh program
page for the computational biology
internship program or the fellowship
program so don't get confused between
these two terms at many places for the
term internship fellowship food is being
used so uh you could find the basic
structure of the research fellowship
program here on the page itself how do
we proceed further so first of all you
all would be supposed to go through a
course material and then come up with
your research proposal submit your
research question and then get started
with your research project and how do we
meet we are going to meet uh twice every
week to take up your doubts and
see your progress and also suggest you i
recommend you the further steps that
should be followed to carry out your
project
and
you can go through the structure here on
the program page which is very well
defined
and to join the uh research fellowship
program you can take up the license here
on the page itself so we have three
licenses the first one is beginners the
second one is intermediate and the third
one is advanced
now uh these three levels are based on
the different types of features uh it
includes
so uh the beginner level does not
include the one-on-one mentorship that
is that you could take up your doubts in
group sessions and also many times
participants are not able to take up
their doubts in a group session uh maybe
because they are not able to clarify
their doubts clearly or they do require
a one-on-one meeting with the mentor so
that could be taken up in the
intermediate license and
then for the advanced license we also
have the technical support that is being
provided along with one-on-one
mentorship and also we have different
types of license on the t bioinfo
platform that elias showed you uh all so
there is a specialization license an
educational license and a research
license now this license has a different
uh provisions that it's going to provide
you to work with your data in the
educational license you would be able to
use the
big data from the various big data
repositories upload the data and work on
it and in a research license if you are
generating your own data or you are from
a lab or a phd student maybe then you
can upload your own data using an ftp
account and carry out the analysis so
this is the page where you can uh just
enroll yourself using
like picking up any of the license that
you would like to
take up and enroll
and
uh
then on this page itself you will also
get to know about the various courses
and
sample projects that you can go through
now all the courses that uh india also
showed you as a part of the research
fellowship program all the courses and
the example projects would be unlocked
for you all so everything here uh under
the courses uh tab
you can go through and learn from
now there is one more aspect that i
would like to share with you all that is
the scholarship application
so we do have a monthly module of
license that you all can take up and be
a part of the program so the module that
i just showed you that is a monthly
module that is you have to take up this
monthly license and carry out your
research work but if you would like to
take up the license uh for a three month
research fellowship program or a six
months program all together then you are
eligible to take up or apply for a
scholarship application as well and this
is the scholarship
application form that i would be just
sharing in the chat box
once you uh fill this scholarship form
we we will review your application and
get back to you um to tell you how much
scholarship you're going to get for the
research fellowship program and that's
the way you can get yourself enrolled
now i would like to leave the stage open
for everyone to take the doubts please
put in the doubts in the chat section or
you can also raise your hand and unmute
yourself to take up your doubt
i just wanted to clarify on a few things
that i have just mentioned and hello
everyone myself mohit mazumdar i'm one
of the commenters and
uh uh and uh representatives who are
working on collaborations today i wanted
to discuss few things with all of you so
we have some
some of the exciting collaborations that
we recently did signing some of the mmus
with some of
the university
departments who are involved in research
some of the departments who are involved
in training and also
industry where
we have people from different pharma
industry and the biotechnology industry
to help students guide
uh through
so
about the licensing um which sonata was
mentioning it's actually a subscription
so
when you're taking a monthly
subscription you're paying monthly these
can be done for in two months three
months and six months the structure
works for
different models so if you are thinking
about taking a two month uh
research fellowship program you can go
for uh either a beginner subscription or
a intermediate subscription or an
advanced subscription so obviously these
are different subscription levels that
are available for you to take by monthly
if you choose to you know take the
mentorship and take all the resources or
the premium resources and develop a
project but obviously you can start from
a very beginner's level that would not
require you to take any license uh not
require you to pay anything
just
join the omixlogic
portal
and then you can also take help from
psionic uh cyanics group as mentioned by
subrajit that would help you develop
such research question and then you can
take the decision to go for big data
analysis so one of the reasons that
there is a subscription to this program
is because that we are um
actually providing you with a platform
to do big data analysis and that
platform itself would require us to you
know uh should give you a lot of space
on cloud as well as access to all the
resources that we have developed that's
why there's a subscription and coming
back to the
question
that crystal has
that she's saying i'm brazilian and have
no money
uh so that's perfectly fine we have
different types of scholarships that are
available for um
different kind of responsibilities so
crystal uh we also have a
research
campus ambassador program
which you can join and one of the basic
objectives of that program is that you
bring awareness about bioinformatics
about omixologic training in your area
and
we kind of get that in a form of a
report and then we provide you a full
scholarship to do this program uh for
three months or six months so that is
also a way to do this for a program
and get supported but that would require
you to give a lot of time uh and effort
and learning and applying all of this so
the best way to develop the project is
obviously
to work directly with the mentor
do the research webinars uh
i mean come and join the research
webinars weekly uh and discuss your
problems so we are available 24 7 and
then there are like online
courses and the portal that you just saw
yeah which is available 24 7. so all of
this uh actually combines to become a
omics logic uh program or a research
fellowship program and um i just wanted
to quickly share with you about some of
the um
some of the
university programs that we have so we
have collaborated with uh amity
university
in jaipur and in noida and if you are a
student there you can reach out to us
and you can let us know and we will be
able to help you
with uh registration relevant to the
university
so um just to tell you about the three
different collaborations and the
collaboration with industry so we
recently
just a second
so
we recently collaborated uh with
amity university jaipur and there's a
reason somehow i'm not being able to
share the full screen and we discussed
about different multi-omics uh courses
and integration of you know
uh integration of our
programs into their internships so
students will be joining from amity
university jaipur today when over 130
people joined and we discussed about the
entire
research fellowship program and
development of projects in group so one
of the way to make it sustainable is to
also work on group project or
collaborative project and all of the
things that we have discussed today and
all of the things that we've been able
to achieve is because of the
collaborations is because of that that
we are working as a team
so one of the biggest aspect of this
kind of you know um
training and this kind of community is
about collaboration is about
understanding each other is about you
know doing uh these uh tasks uh by
dividing the tasks and by
showcasing our own expertise in
different areas
so similarly uh we have a collaboration
uh done with a cgc landrum chandigarh
and then we have launched uh the
research fellowship program for the
students there and they'll be there also
we are working with
department of biotechnology microbiology
and
pharmacy to help students develop
research projects in those areas and
work through these different uh
resources and that all starts from the
basic training that all starts from like
going through those basics that has been
reiterated over and over
and then we do have uh another
collaboration with amity university
noida which turned out to be like a
historic kind of a collaboration because
it involved uh several departments so we
are talking about at least six to eight
departments within amity university
uttar pradesh and then defining of those
research questions during that uh
several uh you know um meetings that we
had so we had brainstorming sessions
where we discussed that how this can be
integrated how the expertise from you
know faculty can be integrated into a
program where we can help students
giving them a holistic understanding of
how to work on or define a research
project and then work with a faculty-led
research project as subrajeet was
telling in his presentation so these are
some of the opportunities that are there
with universities and those universities
who have reached out to us and obviously
we are working on different type of
projects within those universities along
with that one major collaboration that i
would wanted to you know
showcase to you all
is
is uh the collaboration with industry
which is with faba academy which we
recently did and in this meeting we
discussed
about uh how we can help how industry
can help in recruitment how industry can
help in giving job opportunities and we
met with
people here as you can see on the screen
that are
leaders in industry leaders in
biotechnology they are represented in
big pharma companies and they're also
working with ai and drug discovery so
one of the objective of this
collaboration is to be able to develop
resources in data science and ai in
health care and i'll be working very
closely with the group of people here
developing technologies and resources
for students and also giving students an
opportunity to work on projects related
to ai
in drug discovery where we are thinking
about you know small molecules molecule
screening uh in using information from
protein folding structure prediction
using alpha fold uh that you must have
heard about um
that was uh recently came out and
surprised the
the structure of biology world and not
only the structural biology but maybe
the entire world so another application
data science and ai in clinical trials
so this is a huge also when it comes to
ai based drug discovery so what we are
trying to do and what we are trying to
do in this program
would be helping you decide on some of
the important research areas first and
then go to another step to work and
develop the research project so if you
are not sure like which research area
that you are you know
more interested about then you can go
about the intermediate training after
doing the basics that will tell you
about these different
research areas such as precision
medicine population health agriculture
and biotechnology
spaceomics that we discuss in length so
you'll be able to work on 21st century
problems and
i'll be available to help you as a
mentor so i have expertise and over 40
publications in different research
addressing different research questions
using bioinformatics so please feel free
to reach out to me and reach out to our
team and we'll be able to help you go
through and complete this journey and
you already saw the subscription levels
for the research fellowship program you
know about the psionics program and it
will be great if you also can become the
ambassador of these programs and help
others who can be a good fit for this so
with that i would like to conclude
today's session and it was really really
great to see you all and i'd really like
to thank um dr raghavendra and dr
harpreedia and shinali khan subrajeet
for giving us wonderful lectures
throughout this way and we will be
looking forward to meet you next week so
next week also we have a wonderful
session coming up and we'll be emailing
you about that uh on different homicide
programs that we just discussed so we'll
be talking about infectious diseases in
much more detail we will talk we'll talk
about metagenomics we'll talk about
genomics we will talk about
transcriptomics and these specialization
programs are how they are helpful in
developing and in understanding and
finding those research questions
thank you
thank you so much dr mohamed thank you
so much everyone for being a part of the
webinar and making it such a wonderful
event today and
if you have not registered yourself then
do register so that you get the links to
all the groups that you can join and
stay updated about the program thank you
everyone we will be meeting soon bye